Counter-Strike 2 has been out for more
than a week now and is hitting a peak of
over 1 million concurrent players every
single day so surely a game this popular
has to be pretty good right well if you
spent any time online you'd be convinced
the game is actually a hot pile of
garbage some think the game is way too
easy while other exclaim it's utterly
unplayable so is there any validity to
these complaints or do people just need
to shut up and
play
before we get into the video we would
like to thank our sponsors for today our
friends at the shop app over to Liz to
tell you all about it listen we all shop
online I just happen to do it while I'm
playing Cipher waiting for enemies to
walk into my utility and my absolute
favorite place to browse and spend my
hard-earned Moola is using the shop App
instead of aimlessly scrolling through
sites praying I come across something
cool I'm able to find the things I love
and I love the things I find they even
have a personalized shopping feed based
on my style they are on top of my
favorite Brands they're drops and most
importantly their sales and as someone
who is always running around between
work meetings and playing games the shop
app keeps track of all of my orders all
in one place I can order things easily
and quickly with shop pay the app's fast
and trusted checkout best of all if you
live in the US you can get 1% shop cash
every time you check out with shop pay
so spend that shop cash on all of your
favorite participating Brands hundreds
of them run limited time offers so you
can make your shop Cash go further as a
the score Esports fan you can check out
the shop app at
shop. thecore Esports where new users
can get $20 shop cash now go watch the
video okay let me be 100% crystal clear
you are allowed to dislike a game and if
you do you are free to criticize it to
your heart's content at the same time
when you do make a complaint it should
should be warranted and not just
manufactured outrage for Impressions
listen if you spent any time on the
internet you would know exactly what I'm
talking about unfortunately the Nuance
of considered criticism is boring and
people just say the most insane about
any topic just for the attention and I
fear that this issue has seeped its way
into the CS2 conversation to the point
where Talking Heads just post these
outof pocket takes for the sake of
clicks don't get me wrong there are
plenty plenty of grievances you can make
towards CS2 but there is a big
difference between having issues with
the game's audio and making statements
like this I think this game dies CS dies
with two I think it does I firmly
believe that I feel like you're a little
being a little
negative slightly just the truth you
actually think it I think it does I
think this is the end of Counter Strike
does shroud actually have a point here
though no absolutely not there is zero
evidence that Counterstrike will die
with CS2 it didn't die when source
literally split the player base so why
the hell would it now the reality is I
just don't think shroud enjoys
Counter-Strike that much anymore and
he's clearly just trying to get a
reaction out of people and it's
obviously working but to be fair shroud
isn't the only one out here baiting
people to name just a few Loba has been
on an absolute tie rate against CS2 for
God Knows Why since he first got his
hands on it and just yesterday simple
the greatest player in the world said
quote don't play this game right now
wait for updates now while I do agree
with simple's advice of wait for updates
is CS2 a game no of course not listen as
a pro player simple and his colleagues
that agree with him could be right that
this game isn't ort ready I don't play
that level so I couldn't say what I can
say is that I watched and played csgo
since the very beginning and it took
years for that to become Esports ready
but the show went on regardless point is
I ask that you take into consideration
that a simple probably has higher
expectations than most and B he has been
experiencing a ton of issues that might
have nothing to do with CS2 and it
probably influenced his frustrated
comment I'm not trying to invalidate his
or anyone's negative experiences with
the game crashes and poor performance is
absolutely unacceptable and needs to be
addressed but as a massive figure
telling future Pros not to grind the
game that's absolute bait and it just
keeps going it seems like it's almost
impossible to have a Nuance take because
everything needs to be extreme
personally I think this is a larger
issue with social media in general where
things is easy and gets a lot of
interaction but that's a whole
conversation for another day now like I
said there are plenty of valid issues
with this game it was straight up
released with a lack of content the
anti-che needs to be better and
matchmaking is completely unbalanced and
that's just naming a few issues after
the game launched Al Le posted his
biggest issues with CS2 and not only did
I agree with all of them but they were
specific and constructive and guess what
valve is already fixing that be
realistic no CS game in history was
perfect at launch and to this day they
all have their quirks and shortcomings
it's fine to take issue with these
things and not like the game's current
state without needlessly baiting the
community everyone just needs to be more
like Snappy the game is really bad at
the moment um but as professional
players is our jobs to accept it the
game is going to switch and we just have
to adapt we have to play we have to have
positive eyes on it I think everyone
knows that the game is bad currently and
64 tick there's a lot of issues with the
game um and they released it prematurely
but with that said it's our job to
accept that and work with it and try our
hardest and just accept it with positive
arms despite it being a game at the
moment now it can be as easy as just
logging off and sitting down and playing
the game yourself and listen I do plenty
of that and I look forward to how this
game is going to be before the year even
ends but as someone who makes content
for a living this trend is upsetting
because I have to see this every day so
just forgive me I just don't want to see
the CS2 Community go down this path
where it's trendy to all over the game
because it helps no one including the
people who are trying to make this game
better now keep your valid criticisms
tell me about the things you don't like
in the comments and have these
conversations with people online
especially if they're gamebreaking
issues that valve needs to be made aware
of just try not to fall for bait like
this as I did and maybe it will all go
away and listen if you straight up do
not enjoy the current state of the game
right now take a break you honestly
might need to because guess what CS2 is
here and it isn't going anywhere usually
the people that are doing it that are
that are rage posting like that have
like you know ungodly hours in the game
they're the ones playing it the most you
know just like League of Legends you
said like every time some someone brings
up an issue it's usually because they're
addicted to the game and they can point
out every little thing that's not
perfect but it's never going to be
perfect